Guten Tag, mein Name ist Kanar, ich bin als SR Synthetikier, ich würde gerne Ihnen das Annamnesgeschieb erholen,
kurzum Applaus, würde ich nach Ihren Persönlichandaten erfahren, wie heißen Sie?
Ich heiße Frithem Schneider.
Können Sie bitte Ihre Vor- und Nachnamen langsam büchern?
Ja, der Vorname ist S-R-I-E-D-H-E-L-M.
Frithem.
Ja, ein Männername.
Und jetzt mit Schneider, S-C-H-N-E-I-D-E-R.
Okay.
Herr Schneider, wann sind Sie genau geboren?
Am 10.10.48.
Okay.
Wie gross sind Sie?
Ich bin 1,76 m.
Wie viel wiegen Sie so Zeit?
Oh, die 89,90 kg.
Okay.
Was wird Sie so, Herr Schneider?
Ja, mir tut mein Rechtes breit so weh mit einem Mal.
Ich habe zwar schon längere Zeit Schmerzen, aber
jetzt sind die mit einem Mal so stark geworden.
Erst war es nur im Unterschenkel.
Seit ein paar Tagen tut mir auch mein Ober-Schenkel weh.
Ich kann nur noch eine kurze Strecke laufen.
Dann fängt es sofort an, weh zu tun.
Okay.
Wann treten die Schmerzen besonders auch beim Laufen oder im Rohr?
Man gehen, ja, genau.
Ich gehe immer mit meinem Hund spazieren.
Früher konnte ich völlig ohne Probleme mit einem Hund gehen.
Kilometer hat mir nichts weh getan.
Und jetzt irgendwie so im letzten Jahr ist es schlechter geworden.
Kurz vor der Kilometergrenze hat es angefangen, weh zu tun.
Leider.
Was war es, 700, 800 m?
Aber jetzt habe ich das Gefühl, ich komme mal gerade bis vor die Haustür
und dann fängt es an, weh zu tun.
Das ist aber erst ganz neu, seit ein paar Tagen.
Okay.
Wie viele Kilometer können Sie laufen ohne Schmerzen?
Früher konnte ich einen Kilometer laufen ohne Schmerzen.
Dann konnte ich im letzten Jahr ungefähr so 800 m laufen.
Aber jetzt kann ich nur 100 m laufen.
100 m.
Nach der Pause geht dich meistens wieder weg.
Ja, ich muss dann stehen bleiben und ein bisschen rumgucken
und dann kann ich wieder weitergehen.
Okay.
Haben Sie irgendeine Schwälzung oder Überwärmung an den Beinen bemerkt?
Das ist mir nicht aufgefallen, nein.
Okay.
Fühlen Sie sich kribbeln oder...
Das weiß ich manchmal, dass das so komisch taub und kribbelig ist.
Und was mir auch aufgefallen ist, dass die Haut da so komisch schuppig ist.
Das sieht nicht gut aus.
Okay.
Hoffen Sie bemerke das rechte Bein, kühler aus linken Bein.
Ist mir nicht aufgefallen, habe ich aber jetzt auch nicht so richtig drauf geachtet.
Okay.
Im Ruf haben Sie keine Schmerzen.
Nein, manchmal ist das so, dass ich nachts im Bett liege und...
Aber es ist ganz selten.
Und dann habe ich das Gefühl, ich muss mich auf die Bettkante setzen.
Wenn ich die Beine dann runter lasse, dann geht es ein bisschen besser.
Dann kann ich eben einmal auf die Toilette gehen oder so.
Und dann sind die Schmerzen wieder weg.
Aber normalerweise, wenn ich so sitze oder so, habe ich keine Schmerzen in den Bein.
Können Sie gut schlafen?
Nein, also ich muss oft auf die Toilette.
Und eben jetzt, in letzter Zeit, war das manchmal mit den Beinen,
dass die Wege getragen haben.
Wie viel mal gehen Sie auf die Toilette schon mal zu lassen?
Bestimmt zweimal.
Seit wann sind die eine nächtliche Wasserlöste Ihnen bekannt?
Das ist schon viele Jahre.
Was wollen Sie erwarten in meinem Alter?
Ich bin 74, da geht man nachts mal auf die Toilette.
Und wie ist der Verdauungssystem?
Haben Sie Verstopfung oder können Sie...
Eigentlich ist das alles ganz normal.
Herr Schneider, haben Sie Probleme mit dem Atman, Herr?
Mit dem Herzen?
Magnen kann ich auch gut, ja.
Ist Ihnen übel oder schwindelig?
Nein, das eigentlich nicht.
Wie fühlen Sie sich allgemein?
Ich bin verschliesslich.
Was mir aufgefallen ist, dass ich in letzter Zeit das Essen nicht so gut schmeckt.
Das ist mir aufgefallen.
Ich bin ja nicht so ganz zufrieden mit mir.
Ich kann sie wieder.
Haben Sie in der letzten Zeit etwas abgenommen?
Nein, eigentlich nicht.
Sie wissen Sie mehr als vorher?
Ich will nicht.
Nein, ich will es nachts nicht besonders nehmen.
Herr Schneider, Sie können...
Sie haben redet, Orbein und Untersempel beim Raffeln.
Nach einer Pause gehen die Schmerzen wieder weg.
Möchten Sie noch etwas hinzupügen über Ihre aktuelle Beschwerden?
Nein, möchte ich natürlich wissen, wo es liegt und ob man etwas gegenmachen kann.
Ich muss ja mit meinem Mund rausgehen.
Ja, aber ich möchte etwas Medikamente eingenommen.
Nein, wenn ich stehen bleibe, gehen die Schmerzen wieder weg.
Ich habe halt Pause gemacht.
Aber jetzt sind die Schmerzen schon seit 3 Tagen etwas helftig.
Ich hätte gerne etwas genommen.
Wie viele Tage sind die Schmerzen?
Wobei null kann Schmerzen.
Sein Start ist Schmerzen, in der Zeit?
Ja, vielleicht so bei 6 rum.
6?
Das ist schon ziemlich unangenehm.
Sie haben Schmerzen seit einem Jahr gelitten.
Sie haben sich schon mal beim Arsch untersucht.
Ja, ich bin ja immer mal bei meinem Hausarzt, aber von den Beinen habe ich dir nichts erzählt.
Er guckt immer nach meinem Blutdruck und Diabetes.
Aber nach den Beinen habe ich ihm noch nichts von gesagt.
Seit wann ist Ihnen Diabetes bekannt?
Schon lange, seit 10 Jahren.
Nehmen Sie gegen etwas Medikamente?
Nein, ich esse ein bisschen vernünftig, aber Medikamente nehme ich da nicht.
Ist Ihr Blutzucker gut eingestellt?
Wann waren Sie letztes Mal zur Kontrolle beim Arsch?
Ja, wie lange ist das her? Das ist vielleicht so 2-3 Monate her.
War alles in Ordnung?
Ich glaube schon, ja.
Haben Sie weitere Vorarl-Kranken aus der Diabetes?
Ja, das ist alle halb. Ich habe so ein bisschen hohen Blutdruck.
Seit wann leiden Sie daran?
Schon ewig, 20 Jahre.
Was für Medikamente nehmen Sie gegen?
Ich nehme eigentlich so 3 Tabletten.
Eine ist Aspirin, eine ist Klopidogre, das andere ist Symbastatin.
Ich glaube, da ist aber nichts gegen Blutdruck dabei.
Ich weiß nicht, Sie haben auch erhöhte Blutwertwerte.
Ja, das kann gut sein. Vielleicht hat der Arzt mir das nicht so genau gesagt.
Seit wann nehmen Sie Aspirin und Klopidrode gleich?
Noch nicht so furchtbar lange, vielleicht seit 2 Jahren oder so.
Wer hat diese Medikamente in den Geschirr übergeschrieben?
Hausarzt.
Haben Sie sonst welche Medikamente?
Nein.
Wurden Sie schon mal operiert?
Lassen Sie mich überlegen, Ihre Operation hast Sie wirklich noch nie?
Wurden Sie stationär behandelt?
Wenn dann vor langer Zeit, aber jetzt aktuell nicht.
Sind Sie allergisch gegen Medikamente oder Lebensmittel?
Ich glaube nicht so viel, ich weiß, habe ich keine Allergien.
Ich bin bisher so durchs Leben gekommen.
Haben Sie Unverträglichkeiten?
Können Sie alle essen, gut vertragen?
Doch eigentlich kann ich alles essen.
Ja, wissen Sie, ich war früher Gastwirt, da muss man alles essen.
Was machen Sie früher?
Ich war Gastwirt, ich hatte ein Restaurant.
Sind Sie vorstandig geimpft?
Geimpft bin ich auch, ja, ja.
Corona auch?
Ja klar, gegen Corona bin ich geimpft, ja, ja.
Das sollte man ja machen in meinem Alter.
Rauchen Sie?
Ja, ich habe nicht mehr, ich habe früher meine Weile geraucht.
Da bin ich ganz stolz, dass ich das sein lassen habe.
Ich habe nie so richtig viel geraucht, aber lange Zeit.
Wenn man in der Kneipe arbeitet, dann raucht man schon viel.
Wie viele Jahre haben Sie ungefähr gebraucht?
40 Jahre?
40?
Wie viele Zigaretten haben Sie?
Nicht so viel, immer so halbes Päckchen am Tag.
Wann haben Sie mit dem Rauchen aufgehört?
Oh, das ist jetzt, als meine Frau gestorben ist,
wissen Sie, meine Frau hatte Lungenkrebs.
Da habe ich gedacht, jetzt hörst du mal mit dem Rauchen auf.
Also so vier Jahre her.
Das tut mir leid.
Sie haben eine gute Entscheidung getroffen mit dem Rauchen auf.
Trinken Sie Alkohol?
Nicht mehr, also hin und wieder mal, wenn ich mich mit meinen Freunden treffe,
aber eigentlich eher selten.
Früher habe ich natürlich mehr getrunken.
Da hat man jeden Abend so einen Schluck getrunken in der Zeit,
aber ja, schon lange nicht mehr, seit ich im Rente bin.
Sie haben diese Frage nicht probiert.
Rohen? Nein, wirklich nicht.
Sie haben sich irgendwann vor der Krankung geholfen,
wie die Brüder auf der Krankung geholfen haben.
Wahrscheinlich, mein Vater hat den Herz in den Tag,
der ist nicht alt geworden,
und meine Mutter ist mit 75 Analymen im Bund gestorben.
Aber das ist natürlich auch schon lange her jetzt.
Und haben Sie Geschwister?
Die Geschwister habe ich nicht.
Sie sind in Rente zurzeit?
Leben Sie alleine?
Ich lebe alleine, ich habe nur mein Hund, ja.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Nein, wir haben keine Kinder gerade, meine Frau und ich.
Machen Sie regelmäßig sportliche Aktivitäten?
Siehst du, ausser ob ich regelmäßig Sport mache,
nein, also wirklich nicht.
Sie sagten, ich bin mit dem Hund gegangen früher immer.
Das ist ja vielleicht besser als nichts, aber Sport habe ich nie gemacht.
Aber Sie sollten vielleicht jeden Tag zweimal draußen gehen.
Mit dem Hund müssen Sie vielleicht auch...
Ja klar, aber das tut halt jetzt weh.
Ja, okay.
Ich habe es nicht, aber für mich alle, wie Sie es gerade,
Fragen gesiedelt,
möchten Sie etwas ins Frücken?
Ich habe Ihnen jetzt auch eine Menge erzählt,
Sie kennen ja schon mein ganzes Leben fast.
Ich denke mal, ich habe alles gesagt, was Sie wissen können.
Okay, ich werde Sie jetzt für alles untersuchen.
Dann nehme ich Blut ab
Ich werde eine Ultraschall durchführen.
Was wird da untersucht?
Ultraschall?
Ultraschall ist eine Schmerzlose,
sie ist traflich frei und ist eine Versuchungsmethode
für Surbeurteilung von Veränderungen
oder Verrängungen von Gefäßeln.
Sie warten in der Untersuchung 5-10 Minuten.
Das ist ja gut, das geht ja schnell.
Je nachdenkt Ergebnisse von Untersuchungen
werde ich Ihnen die Diagnose sicher sagen.
Sie können mich im Wartezeit warten.
Ich werde Ihnen zurückkommen.
Ja, gut, dann werde ich mich ins Wartezeit machen.
Danke schön.
Ich habe einen Kollegen andere Fragen.
Ich denke, ich habe eine gute Gespräche.
Aber manche Fragen, die meinen macht,
wollen Sie noch etwas nachdenken?
Nein, das ist nicht sehr wichtig.
Aber ich möchte diese Fragen stellen.
Ich habe die Schmerzen in der Übersetzung
von den Schmerzern geblieben.
Die Schmerzen sind drückend.
Ich glaube, die sind auch in Wirklichkeit mehr als drückend.
Die müssen noch eine andere Qualität haben.
Ich stelle die Schmerzen in eine andere Körperregion aus.
Nein, das ist nur auf die Beine beschränkt.
Also auf das rechte Bein besser gesagt.
Ich habe sie schon etwas gesagt.
Ich habe es gesagt, das die Haut
an dem rechten Unterschenkel schuppig ist und nicht gut aussieht.
Haben Sie allgemein Schwöcher prototype Müdigkeit?
Nein, das habe ich nicht so richtig.
Und ich habe das auf das Alter geschoben.
Ja, wir haben nicht.
Haben Kollegen andere Fragen?
Sultana, welchen Labor werdet ihr in diesem Fall antworten?
Ja, das wird ja für die gleiche Zeit, dass sie für Labor werchen macht.
Können wir anfangen, Sultana?
Wir brauchen Mikro-Eier.
Bitte schön.
Guten Tag Frau Oberarschsin.
Ich würde gerne Ihnen einen neuen Patienten
herrschneider vorstellen.
Haben Sie kurz Zeit für mich?
Ja, natürlich.
Ja, herrschneider ist 44 Jahre alt, 1 Meter 46 kuros und 89 kg schwer.
Wie groß ist der?
1 Meter 46, 70.
Ja, wollte ich sagen, okay.
Okay.
Herrschneider, schüttert sich bei uns seit 3 Tagen.
Ich habe die Erkane bis 100 Meter, 15 Lachen.
Auf Nachfrage berichtet er Parästhesie und Parästhesie zu haben
und Herr Schneider hat Hautveränderungen in den Unterschenkelbereich.
Ihre Haut sieht schuppen aus.
Schuppe ich?
Seine Haut.
Die vegetative Anamnesie ist unauffällig bis in Appetanz.
Herr Schneider hat 2-mal Neutrik, aber diese 5-malen, seit längerem,
in Bekannt.
Herr Schneider ist vollständig geimpft und er habe keine Allergie und keine
Unverträglichkeit.
Eine Diabetes Melutus seit 10 Jahren und eine Artrierele-Hypertone seit 20 Jahren
in Bekannt.
Er nimmt Aspirin-Tablet, Klopidogral-Tablet und das Wastetablet seit 2 Jahren ein.
Er ernetzt sich gesund, um ihre Bezüge zu kontrollieren.
Er ist mit 20 Pakonkosmikotinkonsum sehr gelegentlich.
Er ist ein Erwähnenswert, der sein Vater an Herzinfarkt gestorben ist und seine Mutter
in der Erwähnung gestorben ist.
Er hat keine Geschwitze.
Er ist ein Verwittbeer, der vor allem wegen der Lungenkrebs gestorben ist.
Er ist vom Beruf Gastwint und er macht keine sportliche Aktivitäten.
Er lebt mit ihr seiner Hund.
Mit seinem Hund lebt er, okay.
Meine Pardachdiagnose, lautete perfere Artrierele-Parschuskranfheit.
Was wäre Differenzialdiagnostisch noch möglich?
Die Differenzialdiagnostische, die Schialgysendron, die Spinalstösie, die Diabetische, die Neuropathie.
Was machen Sie denn diagnostisch mit ihm?
Ich werde erst den Patienten körperlich unterzuholen.
Bei der körperliche Unterzuholstaste, ihre Gefresse ab.
Ich erwarte in der Beinhaut Veränderungen,
Veränderungen der Blasenhaut, Haarausfall.
Vielleicht eine Atrophieszeichen.
Ich mache einen Lagaruntest.
Bei der Lagaruntest habe ich ihre Unterschenkel an.
Nach 10 Minuten können wir einen Betroffenenbereich,
eine Hautveränderung, Temperaturveränderung,
Farbe und Temperatur verändern.
Das zeigt eine perfere Artrierele-Parschuskranfheit.
Ich weiß, dass ich die Antiografie durchführen würde.
Genau, wenn sich im Duplex da etwas zeigt.
Was wäre die Therapie, wenn sich das bestätigt?
Ich würde mich einsetzen.
Die Patientin sollte diese Therapie weiterführen.
Was soll er noch machen?
Antikorps.
Was könnte man dem noch empfehlen?
Wenn der Akuteverschluss, dann muss man gucken, ob da etwas ist.
Wenn er mit Schmerzen hat, ist er zu vermuten,
dass er etwas sich verschlechtert hat.
Wir reden nicht von Trombose, sondern von PAVK.
Das Problem ist die Verengung der Arterie.
Das ist die Fliesgeschwindigkeit erhöht und ein Wandwiderstand.
Da ist die Frage, ob man das stentet.
Was empfiehlt man ihm dann noch?
Gymnastik.
Gehenübungen.
Die 4 PAVK-Stadien.
Die Patientin geht bis 200 Meter.
Die 2 PAVK-Stadien.
Die 4 PAVK-Stadien können entstehen wie Ulkos.
Negrosen.
Das ist ein guter Punkt.
Untersuchen Sie bitte Herrn Schneider.
Sie machen ein paar Verkürzungen in den Sätzen.
Das Problem ist dieser erste Satz.
Das ist so schwierig.
Ich kann nur raten, dass Sie mehr Sätze machen.
Sie haben das nicht vergessen.
Das Ding hat echt Schöpfen.
Sie müssen den Genitiv nehmen.
Sie müssen nicht nur wegen der Schmerzen,
sondern auch wegen der Schmerzen.
Sie haben viel Salat.
Ich überprüfe noch mal eine formulierte Formulierung.
Ich weiß nicht mehr, was ähnlich war bei den Vorabschankungen.
Sie sind nicht bekannt.
Sie haben das nicht vergessen.
Es macht nichts.
Sie gehen sehr nett auf den Patienten ein.
Sie verstehen alle Nachfragen.
Sie haben die Schmerzen weggehend.
Ich hoffe, dass Sie morgen ein paar Frau Kvk bekommen.
Ich wünsche Ihnen viel Erfolg.
Bis dann.
Vielen Dank.